Knowing the standard widget library is nice,
but as someone who was once accused
as not so much recreating the wheel,
as hand machining my own nuts and bolts,
I know there are times when nothing
in the tool chest will quite do the job.
That's when it's time to dive in and build
your own custom view from scratch.
Now we're not going to be including
any custom views within Sunshine,
but we can still take a look at how
you would build one.
We'll start by creating
a new class for our view.
Let's call it My View.
If you're building
something from scratch,
rather than modifying an existing view,
it should descend from either
view itself, or from surface view.
View offers a lightweight,
canvas-based approach
while surface view is designed
specifically to support UI elements
that require rapid redraws
and/or 3D graphics,
using something like Open GL.
It's perfect for views
that display video or games.
Now the existing widget library
is entirely view-based.
So let's take that approach.
The base view class draws an empty,
borderless, 100 x 100 pixel box.
To change that, we override
the onMeasure handler,
which allows us to indicate the view size.
We'll also override onDraw,
in order to draw our own
custom view content.
Now if it turns out that your view
should always be an empty 100 pixel box
then you're in luck.
Otherwise we need to do some work.
So let's start by setting our view's size.
onMeasure is called
when your view's parent
is laying out its children.
As you know, when you add
a view to a layout,
you can specify a
specific height or width,
but in most cases you'll want to either
match parent or wrap the content.
When a view's onMeasure
is called by its parent layout,
it asks how much space will you use?
And passes in how much
space is available
and whether the view will be given
exactly that much space,
or most of that much space
using these parameters.
You can decode those
parameters like this.
And that'll allow you to obtain
the size and the mode
for your height and width specifications.
In this example we're demonstrating
just for the height parameter,
but it works the same for width.
We can then use the
decoded mode parameter
to find out what size
we should set our view to.
If the returned mode is exactly,
the view will be placed
into an area of exactly that size.
You'll be passed that value if the layout
has specified a specific size
or if the view has been
asked to fill the parent.
In either case, it's best practice
to simply return the value passed in
unless that value is below your
your view's minimum size,
in which case you can return
the minimum value
and rely on the parent layout
to crop or scroll as necessary.
Another alternative is AT_MOST.
This indicates that your view
can define its own size,
up to the size given.
This is typically the case
for views set to wrap content,
where the view should be
as wide as it needs to be
to display its content,
but no wider than that.
And of course, all of that's
provided that it still fits
within the parent container
as indicated by the size parameter.
And we've just finished calculating
all of that for the height parameter
and you'd need to do exactly
the same thing again for width.
Once you've done that
and determined
the size of your control,
you have to call
the setMeasuredDimension method.
Here you pass in your
width and height values.
If you don't call these
setMeasureDimension method,
your app will crash
as soon as your view is laid out.